this video is sponsored by World of
Tanks Jeddah is the financial center of
Saudi Arabia it's an important port city
of 4 million and a major destination for
religious pilgrims Jeddah has a modern
downtown skyscrapers great landmarks
huge malls and the world's tallest
flagpole what it did not have until
recently is a proper sewage system raw
sewage just accumulated in underground
cesspools to be transported by poop
trucks and dumped into the breiman lake
which was quite simply a lake of raw
sewage receiving 1500 to 2 000 poop
trucks per day the sewage leaked into
the natural water rectifiers poisoning
the city's drinking water as the lake
constantly increased in size
environmentalists were warning about a
possible overflow threatening to fly
Jeddah with a massive tsunami of poo
during a 2009 flood it almost did in
fact afterwards the Saudi king ordered
the lake to be drained after 25 years
and set up proper sewage treatment after
building a sewage system Saudi Arabia is
ready to proceed into the next logical
step a giant cube-shaped super tall
golden skyscraper it's called the mukab
and it's the size of 20 empire state
buildings put together it will be the
centerpiece of riyad's new downtown new
murabba which is about one-third the
size of Manhattan but beyond being
stupid ideas the mukab and the new
muraba are also a warning to humanity
that we are headed towards a dark future
a dystopian nightmare so far with no
alternative inside one that will affect
you regardless of where you live the
future is here and it's real
let me explain but first I'd like to
thank World of Tanks for sponsoring
today's video I've been playing this
game for about a decade now which means
I can honestly recommend it it's a free
to play online multiplayer game where
two teams of players shoot each other
with light Tanks medium tanks heavy
tanks tank destroyers and everyone's
favorite self-propelled guns after a
decade of playing sometimes instead of
shooting at enemies I simply fly at them
turning my tank into a 40 ton loiter
ignition for about a few seconds so far
results are mixed but fun there are
multiple ways of playing this game
depending on your preference tank
destroyers are your choice if you like
sniping from cover get some light tanks
if you like art monitoring your enemy at
insane speed heavy tanks if you prefer
to turn forward demolishing everything
in front of you as for medium tanks just
good luck I can't help you and there are
also self-propelled guns if you
especially dislike the enemy team click
the link in the description and sign up
for a World of Tanks using the code tank
Mania and you'll get a tier 5 Excelsior
tank 250 000 credits 7 Days of premium
and three rental tanks for 10 battles
each these benefits are available to new
players only thanks again for a world of
thanks for sponsoring today's video and
now let's continue with the program so
after successfully completing step one
of building a sewage system Saudi Arabia
moves on to step 2 the moocab and the
new muraba downtown which together will
include 104 000 residential units 9 000
hotel rooms one million square meters of
retail space 1.4 million square meters
of office space 1.8 million square
meters of community space and there
should also be a Technical University
theater opera Museum Cinema Gallery
Concert Hall all in all 80 entertainment
venues hopefully sewage treatment plant
as well and in the middle of all this
stent democab a building of truly
monstrous proportions 400 meters wide
tall and long sporting 121 floors and 2
million square meters of floor space but
the true Insanity stores in its very
center which will get to soon don't
worry around democrap the numerable
downtown will be fully walkable designed
around the 15-minute City principle and
I hope you appreciate that because
that's the only good idea about this so
what are the problems with democab let's
go over them
[Music]
let's start with a simple question why
do we build residential office and
commercial buildings well to create
floor space so we can House people
stores offices and so on sure but
sometimes we like to make buildings look
nice even at the cost of floor space so
for example Soviet apartment blocks are
purely practical plane blogs whose sole
purpose is to House people and they're
pretty good at that in contrast the
olive Towers in Paris have these cool
rounded shapes meaning they have less
floor space than the theoretical maximum
but who cares they look cool Aesthetics
can be at the expense of functionality
if done well the mukab takes this
concept Jacks it up to 15 and drenches
it in liquid gold from a furnace fired
by dollar bills if we take a look at the
renders the only Parts with actual floor
space will be these relatively small
Corner sections it seems like the whole
purpose of this giant golden cube is to
house the thing in the center which
don't worry we're almost there according
to plants I mean PR materials the mukabi
is supposed to have 2 million square
meters of floor space while it sounds
impressive for rebuilding the size of 20
MP fire state buildings it's a
ridiculously small amount one Empire
State Building has about a quarter a
million square meters of floor space so
by this Logic the mukab should have at
least 5 million but let's not stop there
let me reintroduce an old friend the
village house the biggest Soviet
apartment building in Hungary its name
comes from the fact that it houses as
many people as a larger hunger in a
village more than 3 000 people in 884
units on 10 residential stories let's
overlay the village house on three
moocab's future location the village
house has 350 meters long so let's add
an extra third to reach the mugabe's 400
meters like this we can overlay 12
village houses on the mukabs footprint
with ample space between them four parks
and amenities now then the village house
plus a third has a floor space of 58 000
square meters per building this Nets us
696 000 square meters of floor space
from the 12 buildings at 10 floors we
already have a third of what the mukap
has with 121 floors and if we extend
each of our 12 10 story village houses
upward to reach the vocab's height of
121 floors we end up with 8.3 million
square meters of lower space more than
four times of what the mukab has and we
even have a bunch of space between the
buildings and if we cover the entire
mass of the Mugabe purely with village
houses we get a whopping 16.6 million
square meters of floor space which I
would say is about the theoretical
maximum now obviously this wouldn't be a
good idea let's not build another walled
city of koblen oh I just wanted to
illustrate how far the Mugabe is from
being given marginally space efficient
it only uses around 12 percent of the
theoretical floor space it could have
and if you're using that little why even
bother with a gargantuan golden desert
Cube to begin with that's because on the
inside they need space for it
the inside of the Muka will be Hollow
with the giant retail Spire in the
middle basically a skyscraper within a
skyscraper and a dome that encompasses
it which is also a giant screen with
Holograms where they'll put up all sorts
of immersive environments for the
visitors entertainment and I mean this
has to be one of the stupidest most
absurd and wasteful ideas I've ever
heard so how do they plan on running
this thing if we take a look at this
render the screen will be about 300
meters in diameter let's also assume
it's 300 meters tall it is then put
together from a 150 meter tall 150 meter
radius Hollow cylinder plus 150 meter
radius hemisphere the internal surface
area of both the hemisphere And the
cylinder are 141 372 square meters each
so in total we have 282 744 square
meters of screen they promised stuff
like Holograms but I think the bass will
be an LED wall with maybe some coated
glass screens in front of them where
they can project additional stuff so
about that led wall let's take some
average heavy duty large-scale modular
LED screens that consume about 250 watts
per square meter on average this would
mean the power required to run the
gigantic screen inside the mukab would
be around 70.
megawatts and this thing would be
running around the clock seven days a
week so the daily average consumption of
the screen would be 1.68 gigawatt hours
which means the power to run this thing
is equivalent to the consumption of
about 58 000 U.S households the size of
a small U.S city so the mukab would
pretty much need its own power plant to
function a plus 4 sustainability but
this project is also part of a larger
overarching problem which should worry
you a lot namely
I consider these increasingly numerous
megalomaniac luxury projects to be a
warning for us all have you noticed that
all these projects are pushed either by
dictators or by billionaires who think
they know what's best for you it's not a
coincidence
the new administrative Capital neon Elon
musk's Morse Colony Dubai and now the
mukab if you look closer all these are
designed to provide a luxurious isolated
safe haven for the ruling class and they
will be absolutely full of surveillance
technology too advertised on their Smart
City features this is a true orwellian
nightmare coming right at us these
projects are the real life Hunger Games
or Elysium the cream of society gets to
live in the city of the future
entertained by giant Dome screens and
Holograms meanwhile the rest of us are
out in the decaying remnants of our
communities trying to Cobble together a
fraction of the living standards that
were default just a few decades ago to
paraphrase slavojijic the world's most
dangerous philosopher rage and
discontent are exploding everywhere and
the old establishment has no idea what
to do they are so called fukuyamaists
meaning they believe that current
neoliberal capitalism is the end of
History the ultimate system and there is
nothing else we can do but to try and
improve it here and there meanwhile it
is increasingly obvious that neoliberal
capitalism is reaching its limits
morphing into a system that only
benefits the top 10 leaving the bottom
90 to fend for themselves
the way money is spread it's kept among
the ruling family it's not spread to the
people only what's left the crumbs are
spread to the people so there's great
inequality between the classes this is
the future coming right at us we see it
happen right in front of our eyes and we
don't know how else to proceed for now
we have no viable Alternatives
the Soviet state is gone the Western
welfare state is dying and the localized
direct democracy would be unable to
tackle problems that require a global
response so what do we do this is the
part of the video where I usually offer
some sort of solution to represented
problems but here I cannot give you a
definite answer actually for the mukab I
can just don't [__] build it Hefty
nice walkable 15-minute City area that's
great but the mukab is completely
pointless just a giant golden Cube entry
into the global dictator's dick
measuring contest Focus your energies on
a sewage treatment plant instead S4
what's the alternative to currently
stage neoliberal capitalism well I don't
have the answer but I can give you some
pointers maybe so let's put our
Collective brain power to use and see if
we can come up with some ideas based on
these pointers first off we need to
tackle the cost of living crisis this
could be done by bringing Public
Services back into public ownership if
corporations are involved in a public
service they will want to make profit
which the consumer pays ultimately
leading to Rising prices Austria produce
energy system under public control and
they pretty much avoided the cost of
living crisis so this is a good start
but the system also needs to limit the
hoarding of wealth at the top the
current system lets corporations grow
indefinitely until they are more rich
and powerful than entire countries so
what if we limited the size of
Corporations somehow we might also want
to ban billionaires altogether in terms
of quality of life there is no
difference between being a billionaire
or a mere millionaire you can afford
anything you want anyway so how about a
100 tax on anything that would put your
wealth above say 500 million dollars
something like that the system also
needs to be able to tackle Global
problems like the climate crisis here we
could have something like the European
Union has a common fund all countries
contribute to proportional to economies
which is then used for projects that
serve the common interest so we could
have this Global Climate fund which is
used to tackle the largest environmental
issues in participating countries these
are some of my basic ideas about how we
could meaningfully change our current
system feel free to take them and if
you're a member of a political party I
encourage you to annoy people with them
at your next party meeting and if you
disagree I'll be interested to hear your
ideas as to how we can avoid the world
of Hunger Games or Elysium thank you for
watching and if you like my content feel
free to join my patreon I post pictures
of my cats there every Saturday and I'll
be seeing you next time